sometimes they just wait
killing time in the summer heat
but never for long
as casualties start coming sent back
from the front line
access there is strictly restricted but
in a day here we had insights into the
battle they're waging a few miles away
Ukraine's counter-offensive is meeting
stiff resistance in Russia's defenses
and minefields
everything here is mind most of these
injuries are caused by artillery
shelling strikes and minefields our guys
have to walk through
the counter-offensive began using
Western supplied heavy armor we're told
but mines have slowed Ukraine's Advance
much of the fighting is on foot now and
it's taking a bloody toll
doctors fight to save ligaments severed
by a mortar that's cut deep into a leg
the patient's a medic himself later
telling us he'd been on the front just
three days before the Russians attacked
I mean nothing
it was a mortar attack we had just
arrived and had to go to our position
well we're an assault Brigade we were
supposed to go to the position and
drones started flying and bombing us
that's what they call a red patient in a
critical condition a Burns victim rushed
from the front line
as he moans they work fast to stabilize
him his limbs shaking in pain
the condition of the patient is serious
taking into account thermal Burns head
upper limbs back completely lower limbs
well the condition is critical you can
use this too
the patient needs urgent intervention
he's transferred to an ambulance
his condition kept stable as they race
through the traffic the quicker he
reaches Hospital the better the odds
there's a specialist Burns unit here
increasing his chances but his life is
still threatened
he have a very big surface that are
injured of skin and unfortunately
prognostically it is not so good as it
could be Ukraine reveals little about
its casualty rate in this war but we've
been given a sense of what its soldiers
are going through and it's clearly not
getting any easier
Dominic wagorn Sky News zapparesia